Hello, I'm Tom Whipple, author and science editor. At the times,
I'm here with Stewart Richie psychologist, professor,
and a frequent debater on intelligence squared.
He is the author of the new book science fictions, exposing fraud, bias,
negligence, and hype in science. Welcome Stewart. Hi Tom.
Hi. Um,
so I think it'd be great to start this discussion where your book starts
because you yourself have some experience of,
for exposing fraud bias and hype in science, um,
and quite an instructive anecdote about how that happened.
You came across a paper, which if it was true,
I think it's fair to say it would have completely changed our understanding of
physics of humanity, of what it is to be a human.
It would be the most important paper in the world.
Pretty much ever people like me, journalists. Uh,
we covered it as that's a bit funny, isn't it quirky,
but you had a different response when it came out to tell us about it.
This was when I was a PhD student. We, uh, we, uh, we're um, I,
I always take an interest in the kind of latest controversies in, in,
in psychology and, and w this is in 2011,
the most controversial paper appear, which was one that, uh,
showed that psychic powers exist. And it was published in, uh, a very, um,
mainstream, uh, very well-respected journal,
the sort of journal where if you get paper in it,
that kind of makes your career in some, in some ways, uh,
people talk about getting, you know,
if you've got three journal articles in this journal, then, you know,
you'll definitely get a job at a good university. So like a really,
really mainstream prestigious place. And it was by a Darryl bam,
who's a social psychologist at Cornell university in the U S
and he, uh, had this amazing study where he had nine experiments, um,
which kind of reversed the usual time sequence of, uh, of,
of psychology studies. So, um, normally in a psychology study, you would, um,
you would show people, uh, maybe so in a memory study,
you would give them a list of words to remember,
then you would remind them of half of the words,
and then it turns out obviously that they would remember the words that you
reminded them all. That makes perfect sense.
But what he did in this study was we made the remainder happen after the test.
So people saw a list of words,
then they were given a test to try and remember those words,
then they were reminded of them afterwards.
And then that was the end of the experiment. And the idea was,
and what he claimed to find in this paper was that the words that they were
about to see in future were remembered better on the test.
So, um, this is like, um,
you study for an exam and then you sit the exam and then you study again after
it. And that's some who looks backwards in time to help you on the exam that you
just did, which is obviously like a mind blowing thing. And kind of,
it takes a few seconds, even when you're reading the paper,
you think is really far, and you kind of, you have to clarify, like, um, uh,
get yourself into a complete different frame of mind. So,
but that was published in a mainstream journal. So what we thought we would do,
we would, we would try and replicate it.
We would try and run the same experiment again, uh,
using exactly the same software, exactly the same memory test, exactly the same,
everything, um, uh, on our undergraduates, um,
back when I worked at the university of Edinburgh. And so we, we published, uh,
we, we did that replication and no,
no surprise there that we didn't find a positive result. We found that people,
um, did not remember the words that they were about to see they weren't psychic.
Um,
and we tried to publish that paper in the same journal that had been published
in the original, had been published in, uh, the one, uh, um, the, the,
the journal of personality and social psychology it's called.
And that what they said to us instantly was, um,
we do not accept replication studies.
We do not consider a publication that publication of replication studies under
any circumstances. Um, and that really shocked me because, um,
they had published the original they'd published the original really exciting
finding that it was kind of mind-blowing and got on the news and that, you know,
the author got on the Colbert report in the U S it was like a big deal,
but they wouldn't even consider publishing something that said actually,
maybe people aren't psychic. Um, and so, um, that kind of stands in,
I think for quite a lot of science where the focus is on exciting new
groundbreaking findings and not on findings that are probably more likely to be
true, but are maybe a bit more boring. Yeah.
Yeah. And this,
so the interesting thing about your book is I think the people who've been
following this will know about this thing, that's called moving capital letters,
the replication crisis, uh,
and a lot of psychology has fallen down.
Um, a lot of things that we, we sort of still a common knowledge,
the sort of things that you would repeat at dinner parties, you know,
the Stanford prison experiments,
the power posing where suddenly the whole conservative party cabinet were
standing like sort of slightly in constant Cowboys on the conference stage.
Um, and all of these things that, you know,
I think a lot of people heard about these falling. They thought, yeah,
that figures that sort of slightly too easy, Ted talk kind of thing.
Um, but what you're saying is that far from being a problem with psychology,
this is, there are generalized problems here that spread into other disciplines.
Yeah, absolutely.
I think psychology has been the field where we've looked at this most, uh,
most kind of systematically, like there's been these large attempts, you know,
because of problems like the psychic experiment and various other things that
happened around about 2011 and 12 since then,
psychology has been much more aware of this problem.
And so we've systematically start to look at it.
So we've got a good idea of the problems in psychology,
although there's still debate over, you know,
exactly what is reliable and what isn't, as you would expect,
scientists are constantly debating and arguing. That makes sense. But, um,
we have indications that there are the same kinds of problems in other areas of
science as well. So, um, uh, even if you, you know,
if you start off in fields that are kind of closely allied to psychology,
like economics and so on,
and they've done some replications surveys and find similar problems, um,
then you, you,
you kind of move out further into more kind of what you might call hard sciences
a little again, that's not a term that a lot of people like these days, but, um,
harder sciences like physics and chemistry and so on. Um,
I think probably they have less problems in, in those, in those, uh, um,
disciplines they have, you know, um, slightly more, uh, control over the
Germans, uh, less, um, kind of fickle human beings in their, in their, in their,
you know, as, as their, as their test subjects, they can,
they can really control things in a, in a, in a more, uh, in a stronger way,
but there are glimmers of the same kinds of issues, um, fraudulent, uh,
scientists publishing papers, uh, and getting away with it for years. Um, uh,
unreplicable experiments being retracted surveys of scientists that say that
they've tried to find the same result as a previous paper phoned,
and they've been unable to do that. Um, and, and even ones, you know,
you see this quite a lot, for instance, in, uh,
in computer science algorithms and so on, um,
people being unable to even make the same experiment work again, uh,
even if you use exactly the same code and exactly the same data. Um,
so you know, all these algorithms that are published in journals,
people take the code and go, okay,
I'll run that and maybe try and extend it in some way,
and then they can't even get it to work in the first place.
So we've got all these problems.
And the scariest of all of course is when it happens in medicine.
And we don't have these treatments that are used in,
are written up in medical guidelines and recommended doctors.
And then another study comes along and completely contradicts. Um,
what was the case before?
Probably because the quality of the original studies on which the original
recommendation was based was really poor.
So for listeners who aren't familiar about how science works,
how should it talk me through the ideal, if you were,
if you were describing this sort of pure mechanism that humans have derived for
finding knowledge and furthering our race, how should it work? What, what, from,
from the experiment to the publication, to what comes next,
what should be happening and what are the checks and balances?
It shouldn't be that well.
Normally you would expect. I think if you ask people, you know,
what they expect scientists to do,
the idea would be that they would come up with a strong, uh,
experiment before they've even really looked to the day. They come up with,
come up with an experiment.
They come up with an idea of how to analyze that experiment and then write it
all down and plan it all out. And then they go and collect some data. Then the,
uh, once the data are in the run, their fiscal analysis, maybe even,
uh, they get someone else to run the circle analysis. Who's not, you know,
part of the same, who's not, doesn't have the same biases and so on.
And then they would submit it to the ultimate system of checks and balances,
which is of course the peer review system, uh,
where you send your article off to a journal, you pick a journal that's, uh,
you know, particularly close to your field. You know, you would, uh,
for the experiment we talked about before is the journal of personality.
Social psychology is very clear what the public is.
So kind of specific to psychology journal. Um,
there are also the general journals,
like nature and science and things which publish, uh, you know,
results from across the sciences. And then the editor of that journal.
If they're interested in the paper, we'll send out to, um, your colleagues,
your peers for peer review, um, uh, and, uh,
they will give a completely disinterested look at the paper and analyze it
statistics and stand back and say, does this make sense? Does this work,
that we'll dig into the details and, uh, and, and, and look at the, um,
whether your numbers make sense and so on. And then, uh, you will, um, uh,
get your publication and you'll get your light on your CV.
And you'll be very pleased. And, uh, and so on,
you've made a contribution to the scientific, uh,
the scientific literature.
The problem is that at every single stage of that process, that's the ideal, um,
at every single stage, all sorts of biases and failures and,
and issues come in and not for them.
Okay. So let's, um, let's start. Where does,
where does the first bit of [inaudible].
If you ask again, if you ask just someone who, you know,
who wasn't an expert in science, you've just asked them, you know,
do you think scientists plan out their analysis beforehand,
or do you think they collect the data and then kind of just do the analysis kind
of ad hoc as they go along and kind of let themselves do anything as they,
as they, as they go through? Of course they would say that it was the former,
but actually the vast majority of cases,
scientists are just kind of running an analysis, ad hoc as the,
as they go along. There's no plan.
Normally there's sometimes a very vague idea of what they're going to do once
they get the data. But the problem is that when you run your analysis ad hoc,
you allow yourself to be, um, to be dragged along in different directions.
And you can introduce lots and lots of biases into your, um,
into your, into your experiment. Now, um, uh, one of the,
one of the major biases of course, is that people want to find positive results.
They want to find statistically significant results. Uh, and, um, uh,
if you look across the literature, you find that in,
in subjects like psychology, um, about 90 something percent of,
of experiments have positive results,
which you wouldn't necessarily expect if scientists were just trying out new
ideas and some of them failed, and some of them were true and, you know,
they just, you know, they, they were, they were, um, they were kind of, uh,
really properly experimenting with the world.
But actually what you find is that 90% of them or more are, uh, are,
are positive, which implies that we're not seeing the ones that didn't work.
We're not seeing the blind alleys, we're not seeing the, the, the, uh,
experiments. Um, and so these kind of these two things I've mentioned,
the statistical biases and the bias towards finding positive results work
together. And you're really insidious way, which is that they, uh,
which is that scientists sometimes unconsciously run their analysis in such a
way that they find positive results. And the reason that they do that of course,
is, is that the journals won't post the results.
They want the exciting flashy results.
Like I've mentioned with that psychic study. Um,
they themselves want to find positive results because it's cool to find positive
results.
You want to be able to show that you've advanced the literature that you've
advanced the treatment of a disease, or, uh, discovered some new,
exciting knowledge about the world. Um,
and what you don't want to find is that your treatment idea didn't work.
Your trial was a failure, your, um, you know, your,
your new mechanism for how some, uh, um,
you know, some psychological trait works with actually not true, you know, so,
so, so, um, you, you wanna, you want to, uh, find positive results.
So that's the first place that the, the, the,
the bias comes in is that scientists make the decision as to whether to publish
stuff on the basis of what the results were.
So the ju just to explain that,
to read as an example in your book, um, I think,
I think with this, this is something that's called P hacking. Um, uh,
and I think the canonical example of that is probably someone that most people
will have heard of they'll have heard about how,
if you keep on filling a soup bowl from the bottom and you'll eat indefinitely,
or if you take a bigger plate to a buffet, you'll fill it up faster.
How will these are glorious results? I'm along the journalist,
I'm waiting for the bit where you get to how we screw up the process,
but one of the ways is we absolutely love stories and
ruin the story for me.
Well, unfortunately, yeah, a lot of those findings have come into question. So,
and this is this, this is the, the, um, this is Brian Wansink,
who was a professor again at Cornell.
And I don't have an animus against Cornell university. It's just,
that happens to be that, that that's where these results were from. Um,
Brian Wansink, uh, was the head of the Cornell food and brand lab.
And it was his idea that they had this bottom was bowl, as you say.
And it was also his idea that bigger plates, if you take a bigger plate,
you'll put more food on it. And these were fine. Like, as you say,
everyone knows this, and there were published in, you know, psychology, food,
psychology journals. Um, he wrote a really unfortunate blog post in, I think,
2006, um, towards the end of 2006, he wrote, sorry, I turned 16. I should say,
wrote this really unfortunate blog post, where he said, um,
I really like it when my students just get,
they gather a whole bunch of data with a whole bunch of stuff,
and then they just keep analyzing it until they find something.
And then we publish that. Um, and, you know, as I was just talking about it,
I don't think that's how most people would understand that scientists do stuff.
They think that scientists would come up with an idea and then test whether it's
true and then published whether or not it was true. Um,
but actually what he was admitting to doing inadvertently,
I don't think he realized that he was saying this,
but what he was admitting to doing was just collecting a bunch of data dredging
through it until he finds anything. Um, and, and then publishing it.
And the reason you can do that is that, uh,
the more you run the statistical tests that most scientists use to check whether
the result is, is, uh, is, is true or not, or is, uh, is,
is just due to fiscal chance or not, which is a statistical significance test.
Um, and you get, you get that. You get a P value from that,
which is where the term you used P hacking comes in. Um,
the more change you run that test, the more likely you are to be fooled,
essentially to be shown,
to attempt to find a test result that looks like it's a positive result,
but actually it's just due to chance. Um, and so, um,
this, um, this,
this problem becomes really acute when you're just dragging through and just
running more and more and more, more tests check with her check with her men,
uh, pay more in tips when there's a woman, uh, with them at the, at the table,
or whether it's a man check, whether, um, they,
they pay more in tips when it's a pizza versus it's, it's past that check.
Whether, you know, you can do all these, you know, if you collect enough data,
you can just keep running tests until you find a result and then,
and then publish it. And that is what he was admitting to doing. So,
unfortunately at that point,
people started looking into his research and finding all sorts of really sloppy
errors, really sloppy mistakes. And even he was, he was accused of,
uh, by his university, who've actually did an investigation of misconduct,
not necessarily fraud, and that he wasn't making the data up,
but he was analyzing them in such a way that,
that it was essentially meaningless the results. Um, and so he's, he's actually,
he's retired from his position now, he's, he's, he's gone. Um, uh, because,
you know, he just wasn't really doing science.
He was doing kind of dredging through numbers and statistical noise. Uh,
um, and if you know, there's enough statistical noise around that,
you can find basically wherever you want, if you have a big enough data set.
Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. And then, so, so I I've, I haven't P hacked I've,
I've got my paper through with, uh, legitimate statistical analyses. Um,
what's the next.
This goes wrong. The problem that, that can then come in is that, um, so you,
uh, you,
you have to also have made sure that you haven't made any mistakes in your
analysis. So, um, you know, P hacking can be completely unconscious,
but another unconscious problem is that a lot of people just sloppily make
mistakes and, you know, copy and paste errors and these lab.
But assuming that you've not done any of that,
the next problem comes when you're actually communicating it to the world. So,
um, when writing the papers, uh,
scientists spend an awful lot of time hyping up their results.
So I'm writing papers as if, uh,
the results were the most important thing ever to be discovered on this,
on this topic. Um, the classic line about, you know,
this has implications for, and then, you know,
it might be the treatment of mental health disorders,
or this has serious implications for how we understand X, Y,
Z thing about the world, whatever it happens to be, um,
scientists love seeing things like that. And again,
it's from it's because of pressure from the journals,
the journals want to publish papers that, uh,
that discover exciting new things about the world.
So scientists write up the papers in ways that kind of decouple themselves from
the data, the actual, you know, the texts, which is what most people read,
especially if you don't understand this, this takes, and most people,
even who are scientists don't understand the statistical methods that are used
in other fields. So, you know, we're looking at the, the, you know,
the discussion section and the paper that tells you the, the implications. Um,
they write it in such a way that makes the,
is it goes way beyond what the data have actually shown. Um, and then, uh,
they often then move towards, um, uh, you know,
actually taking the, the beyond the scientific journals and into the real world,
which is where press releases come in.
I think a lot of people think that press releases are just written by, um,
are just written by, uh, uh, you know,
PR people at universities and so on, but actually they're,
they're in many cases written by the scientists themselves. Um,
and that's a place where there's no peer review,
so you can see whatever you want is actually,
and people make up all sorts of stuff about the research and in press releases.
They,
they jumped from correlational research to causal conclusions that jump from
research that's in mice or in rats to this is definitely true in, in, in,
in humans. Um, they jumped from, um, a study of, uh,
just a few people to, this is definitely a how everyone should, you know,
eat or exercise or treat their kids or whatever it happens to be. Um,
so, uh, the scientists themselves,
I think a lot of people blame journalists and blame PR people and so on it,
but it's the scientists themselves that are often the source of this hype, um,
when, when, when results go out into the real world.
Yeah. Yeah. There's a, um, I endorsed,
you're blaming of people who aren't meat. Uh, uh,
there's a,
quite a nice sort of examples slash parable in your book where
you talk about, uh, because at the moment we've chatted about funding,
things like soup bowls and paranormal, but, uh,
this is obviously this a very serious side, as you've made clear.
And you talk about studies into antidepressant, um,
and there was a kind of study of studies where the scientists looked at a
hundred, um, I guess pre-registered, um,
studies and looked what actually happened. And I don't know if you can remember,
but can you talk through what happened to these hundred papers?
Yeah, it's an incredible study actually. And it's got this really, it's got,
it's really vivid figure,
which I reproduced in the book where you can see at the start, there were, um,
actually of the studies that were registered because clinical trials have to be
registered before you, uh, before you, uh, run the study. That's,
that's the only kind of study where like legally you have to register them. Um,
so we know all the clinical trials that are taking place unless they're done the
legally, which I think is not very, it's not very common,
but we know that they're all taken. We know which ones are taking place. Um,
and then it turned out that, you know, about 50, 50, um, uh,
in half the cases the drug works and half the cases, it didn't,
so you've got about 50 50, but then you see the process of, um,
uh, the negative results basically disappearing. So we know that they exist.
We know that they happened,
that the trial was run that had those negative results,
but as you go through the process of, uh,
of which ones get chosen to be published in journals, um,
and it's basically all the positive ones get published and all the negative
ones, uh, just kind of dissipate and you just have a few negative ones there.
Then you go through the,
of how they're actually written up in the papers themselves,
and you find no results, um, uh, often becomes subject to spin. So,
uh, they are, they're written verbally as if they were, you know,
kind of almost there. And this, this probably works kind of the old, sure.
The statistics didn't show that it works, but, but probably it works, you know,
and you can write it up in a, in a kind of spun way like that. Um,
and then actually by that, by the end,
they show that the studies that got positive results were cited more by other
scientists than the ones that go out negative results as well.
So by the time you've been through those process,
you change the real scientific literature from, which was about 50,
50 into something where I don't know, I can't remember the exact numbers,
but it's like 90% positive or something, or even worse than that.
Yeah. If you, you dropped, um,
50 odd papers that were negative to basically five.
Yeah. It's incredible. Really when you, when you see it like that,
and it's not just antidepressants, you know, this, this happens,
they showed in that same paper that it happens for studies on, um,
for trials of, of psychotherapy as well for depression. Um,
but I'm pretty sure given all the other evidence that there is publication bias
and all these issues that this happens for lots of other, um,
for lots of other topics as well.
Yeah. Yeah. Um, so I mean,
I'm listening to this and regularly when you look at surveys, um,
scientists are always the most trusted profession. Um,
journalists very unfairly are always the least trusted profession other than the
state agents. Um, are we right? Well, first of all,
are we right to trust you all? And secondly,
is this the result of scientists overly selecting
for malevolent and deceitful individuals? Um,
or is there something else going on about the way that science works,
that chronic decent people and
being in this, this system where this is how it works.
We were right to trust the idea of science we're right.
To trust the process of science, the, the methods of science. I mean,
there's no,
one's such thing as the scientific method and philosophers have argued for a
long, long time about that, but, you know, were,
were the basic principles of science are Bulletproof, as far as I'm concerned.
Um, it's the, it's the way that those are instantiated in the world, uh,
and the way that those are essentially acting in academia, that becomes,
that becomes problematic. So, um, uh, we're totally, we're totally,
uh, the, the idea of doing peer review is a great one where you're,
you're asking for outside scrutiny of, of results. Um,
but the way it's instantiated is, well, you're, you're, you, you know,
you give a paper to other scientists who are themselves busy scientists with
other stuff on their minds. You give them a time limit to do it.
You don't give them any additional reward or P to do it.
You just get them to do the goodness of their heart.
And they're probably going to do, you know, a not great job on it. Or,
or in many cases, they're not going to do a great job on it. Um, of course,
lots of peer reviewers are really heroic and that they, they, they still,
despite all that stuff still do a great job, but, um, but, uh, you know,
in many cases you can see why they would,
they would be rushed and they would not notice errors in papers.
Dodgies discal analysis, even sometimes fraud, you know,
slips right through the neck.
So you can see how that's a system where in theory it's great,
but in practice it's, it's, it really,
it really doesn't work and it's full of holes and interrupt.
Because you've, um, we've been talking about all the serious stuff,
and I want to give a sense that your book's really good, fun as well.
And the section on peer review is, uh, you, uh,
you talk about how I hadn't realized that peer review was quite a new thing. Um,
and that when Albert Einstein got peer reviewed here,
he announced he was drawing his paper from consideration because that
send it through another physicist. We comment. And then you look at, uh, you,
you show some real peer review comments and you can sort of sympathize with
Einstein. Um, what, my examples, you quote,
the manuscript makes three claims. The first we've known for years,
the second for decades, the third for centuries, or my,
my favorite I'm afraid this manuscript may contribute not so much towards the
field's advancement as much towards it's eventual.
These are these glorious.
Great quotes, genuine quotes from peer reviews and, um, uh, that they, um,
you can,
you can imagine getting that it's still demoralizing when you get that sort of
comment in your, in your, in your review. Um, but you know,
I don't know if we want it to be any other way,
because we want science to be rigorously, you know, analyzed.
And we want people to be, to be honest and peer reviews. And that's one of the,
it's both the upside and the downside of peer reviews is that you can be honest
if you're, uh, you know, sometimes, uh, in know, journey junior academics,
even sometimes PhD students are asked to review papers and they can say,
because they're anonymous, they can say,
actually this paper by this really big professor,
this really important professor at presented university is completely bad for
all these reasons is, is, is terrible for all these reasons. And,
but of course the downside of peer review is exactly the same thing,
which is that people can trash papers that they disagree with because the theory
doesn't fit with their preconceptions or whatever. So you get these, all these,
um, these hilarious, uh, comments,
and I've had plenty of them myself over the years,
and I've given some over the years, uh,
just you and one tries to control himself, but, um,
sometimes you see something that's just so daft that you can't, uh, you can't,
um, uh, control yourself. So, so yeah, so that's one of the,
one of the problems is with peer review. Um, uh,
but to go back to your previous question, the, the,
the overall problems that I identified in the blue car, or with th the, the,
the, the, the general setup of academia,
which is that the incentives are all wrong.
The incentives are towards publishing more papers. You know, I mentioned you,
you get that line on your CV. That's what people want.
That's what people are looking for in sciences is getting a longer CD,
having a paper published, especially if it's published in a,
in a really glamorous a journal, like a really, really great outlet,
a great publication, like nature or science or places like that. And, um,
and they're not necessarily incentivized towards getting true results,
getting results that are real gain results that are going to stand the test of
time, and that are robust to, uh, other, other people's, um,
you're trying to replicate or extend them. So the whole system of universities,
that's how universities reward researchers. They, they, they promote, uh,
and give tenure to researchers who have lots of papers on their CV. Um, they,
uh, funders are more likely to give you, you know, uh, funding,
if it looks like your ideas are flashy and exciting and so on.
And they're less likely to be interested in, you know, SLU,
replication studies building up a foundation and so on.
So the same kind of incentives that apply to, um, uh,
journalists who are looking for exciting stories, as you, as you say,
apply exactly the same to, to universities, funders, journals, the whole,
the whole system that's around science. And that really knocks it off track of,
you know, which is it's meant to be finding things that are true.
It knocks it off towards, you know,
just publishing stuff and publishing it in glamorous places.
So how do we, how do we fix this.
Different things? Uh, so, um,
one of the things we we've previously mentioned is the clinical trials,
for instance, are, uh, you have to register clinical trials before you,
before you start.
So one thing would be for scientists to start writing down their analysis before
they, before they really do them, um, uh, writing,
writing down and a proper detailed analysis plan.
Like I think most people would assume scientists would be doing, but they don't,
um, uh, and putting it somewhere public and saying,
this is what we're going to do. And if we do anything different than, you know,
you can see, you can see that we've changed the plan there.
You can see that we've, we've kind of, we've, uh,
we've been unable to resist running another analysis, like in the,
like in the pizza restaurant, one where the person is just doing the same, uh,
doing, doing, analyzing the same dataset over and over and over again. Um,
so pre-registering analyses like that is something that I think most sciences
can learn from clinical trials. We can learn that, that that's a really good,
that's really good idea. Um, journals can change the way they, uh, uh,
reward or their publication strategies.
There are no publication strategies where scientists can send in, uh, um,
an introduction, uh,
kind of introductory section and their planned method and get it reviewed before
any data are collected. And the journal agrees to publish the paper,
whether or not the results are positive or not. So that takes, um,
that takes away all the problems of publication bias,
because you've agreed beforehand that you're going to publish this paper no
matter how it turns out. And then you go off and do the actual data collection.
And so journalists can change the way they do that.
Scientists can change how open and transparent they are.
They can start sharing their data with each other at the moment,
if you email scientists and ask for the data, say,
they're normally extremely reluctant to give you that, um, in some cases,
because they worry that they've made a mistake in some cases,
because it's just a mess that they have an annotated it properly,
and that would be able to understand, um, except themselves, um,
which I think is not really an adequate excuse for not sharing your data,
but it's a very common, uh, thing. Um, so that's another, that's another thing.
Um, universities can change the way they hire people.
They can hire scientists who are open and who, uh,
contribute data and contribute tools for people to use rather than just hiring
people who have long CVS. Um,
so there are lots of different changes that can be made at different levels in
your bottom up and top down changes that can meet.
And some of them are being made. Um, I am somewhat optimistic. Um, but, um,
I have to say that, uh, certainly in recent times with the COVID-19 pandemic,
um, I am, um, seeing a lot of the problems kind of, uh, uh, come,
come up again and again and again, um,
despite all these changes that people have tried to make.
So we've, I mean, we've, COVID, um,
we've had the greatest explosion of scientific research, I think,
in, in human history. Um,
it's been a massive global collaborative effort. What,
what are your worries about the way in which this has been done?
Um, I think the main worry is that it's being done really quickly. Um,
and one of the biggest problems with that publish or perish culture that I was
just describing is that, is that people do research too fast.
They peer review research too fast.
They publish research too fast and allows all sorts of mistakes and,
and corner cutting to, to, to come in. Um,
we just recently started a case where two papers were attracted from two of the
top medical journals in the world,
the land sets and the new England journal of medicine, because the,
the Harvard researchers who published them, this was on the drug, uh,
had dropped a chloroquine,
the Harvard researchers who published them had not looked at the data that they
had been provided by, um, a company who had apparently come up with these,
with these data on patients who've been given hydroxychloroquine and it just
rushed to publish the papers, uh, and, and, and get them out there in these,
in these top journals, it's absolutely mind boggling.
It turned out that the data had loads of had loads of problems,
and that they'd been questioned in various ways.
And it looks like they're going to have to be, um, uh, well,
they've been retracted,
but investigations are continuing and to exactly what has gone on with those,
with those data. But, um,
imagine that imagine publishing data in the top journals in the world without
having really checked it yourself. And when you check it, uh,
the person that gave you, it says, Oh, sorry, I can't,
I can't provide you with that idea, but that's astonishing. And that's a,
that's an example of how the haste that the pandemic has given us has really,
um, pushed her, you know, science, uh, off a cliff in, in, in, in many ways.
We've also seen really Georgie research on masks. Uh,
we've seen dodgy research on other,
other drugs that are related to the varsity scenes,
all the research on the genetics of the virus, um, uh, on,
on the psychology of the, of the, of the virus. Um,
and a lot of it comes from just people thinking, Oh, I can be helpful here.
My field is, you know, related in some way to the, to the pandemic. So I'll,
I'll publish another paper. I mean,
a lot of the research is not necessarily damaging in any way. It's just,
it's just useless. Or like, like, did we really need the paper that was, um, uh,
about how COVID relates to the finger length, but the, the,
the relation between your second and fourth finger, the ratio of, of lent,
like there's a paper published in the literature on that too.
Do we really need, but how does it make a great story?
No, I can't even remember.
I can't even recall a result of it cause I was just like, Oh, w when I saw it,
you know, it's a, it's a common method that is used in, in, in,
in testosterone and so on. And it's been kind of debated, but like,
it's not really something new. And, um, uh, you know,
there's loads of psychology studies that have come out hundreds of studies,
which are things like we've developed a new questionnaire to ask people how
scared they are of COVID and here we tested it in our sample, in our sample.
Understandable. I mean, fair enough, but there's, but there's this huge, um, uh,
uh, upsurge of research, as you say. Um, a lot of it is, is waste.
A lot of it is, uh, is, is, is, uh, is, is done too quickly. Um, and,
and a lot of it is just playing wrong, unfortunately. So it's kind of,
it's not really showing science in very good late.
And to what extent, I mean, you may, you make quite a powerful case and,
you know, in some of the fields, you'll find, we're finding when,
when we do these analyses, um, you know,
it's picking up research, that's bad, fraudulent,
doesn't replicate at very, very significant sensors. I mean,
percentages that, you know, 50% plus in some cases, um,
why are humans making progress at all? If this is the case,
it feels like there's a bit missing from this picture that despite these
imperfections, we are bumbling forwards and doing our thing. Yeah.
Shouldn't we shouldn't, uh, you know, push the, the,
the argument too far and say that, you know, all the, all the, everything is,
uh, is untrustworthy and so on. It's just,
it's just that we would be making such better progress if we could get over
these problems that we have in literature,
we would be making such quicker progress on diseases like COVID,
but also all the other diseases that we study we'd be making much better
progress, but understanding the world and understanding space and understanding,
uh, the human mind and all the other stuff that we're interested in,
if we didn't have all these things are slowing the progress of science, then,
um, uh, all these academic issues that we could, we could solve, you know, by,
by changing the incentive structure by changing the rules. Um, although, I mean,
issues like fraud,
people making results up and so on will always be with us because humans are
humans and they occasionally do these kinds of things, but yeah, um,
we clearly are still making progress and I wouldn't want the book to be, um,
you know,
use if I rate the writers in the book as an argument against science in general,
uh, I don't want it to be used for people who are, you know, anti-vaccine or,
or, uh, against, uh,
the idea that there's manmade climate change or whatever,
whatever weird unscientific idea people want to have.
The idea is that we should raise our standards across the board, um,
and that we should raise our standards for all science, including the, you know,
the stuff that's published in the very top journals. Um, and so, uh, uh,
a lot of these ideas, like, you know, climate,
climate denial and anti-vaccination and creationism or whatever it happens to
be, wouldn't stand up to this new, uh, raised really standard anyway.
So it's not like people who are critics of science from a kind of unscientific
perspective will get much out of this. I hope.
Yeah. Yeah. One of the causes for hope, um,
that I found on reading,
it was the ingenuity of some of these tests that are able
to look at papers on mass and,
and there are loads of them they're quite complicated to go and do some of them,
but look at papers on mass and find out just even from what's published in the
paper automatically, or there's a problem here.
And one of them that I felt was it was very clever and just about
understandable, um, and also had a brilliant acronym, uh,
was the grim test. Are you able to describe this?
So as I was actually looking at papers and just trying to find the ones that are
a bit iffy.
I can do my best. Yeah.
So this is the granularity related inconsistency of means test.
So grim for sure. It's, it's a great, it's a great name. And this is by, uh, by,
uh, uh, Nick Brown and James Heathers who are, um,
kind of data sleuths who look into, uh, dodgy, dodgy papers.
Um, well,
they look into all papers and they discover a few dodgy ones occasionally. Um,
but what this does, is it discovers, um, uh, so often in,
particularly in areas like psychology, you've given people a scale,
maybe from zero to five of like, I don't know how happy they are with their,
how happy they are with their job or happy they are with their family life
around the city and they'll rate that.
But it turns out that there are only certain ways say that you have a sample of
20 people that you've given that, that test to,
there are only certain numbers that can come out of that. If you average,
if you take the average score.
So like maybe it's possible that you could get a score of 3.49,
but it wouldn't be possible to get a score of 3.47 or a score of 3.4. I'm not,
I would need to do the math for the second.
Because it's, while you're trying to stand it,
I think it's just with two people with two people,
you can either get a whole or.
Right, right. That's true. That's true. Yeah. So if you,
if you have two people in your average score, you can either get, um,
point 0.5 or you can get 0.0 at the end of the number. There's no other,
if you get, if you get a 0.37, uh, after, after the,
after the number you've done something wrong, there's something wrong with this,
with the analysis that you've done or the calculation that you've done. So, um,
what they do is they look through the averages that are published in, in, uh,
in, in papers and the tables and papers.
So they don't even need access to the raw data. They just need,
the average is published in paper. Um, and they say, well, wait a minute,
that number is impossible. If it, either,
either you've described the wrong sample size,
so that's a mistake or you've described the wrong average. So that's a mistake,
or you've just described your questionnaire completely incorrectly.
So that's some mistakes, so something must be wrong. And in some of these cases,
uh, it's laid on to, um, discoveries of actual fraud. Like the people,
the reason that the numbers are, uh, are, are, are not,
are not possible is because they're made up. Um, and the,
and the fraudster didn't make them up in such a way that made them look
realistic, which is, you know, something was to love fraudsters for gay is that,
is that you need to actually meet your data,
look as if they came about naturally. And not that they were, you know,
made by a human being. Um, uh, uh, and, um,
in some cases it's just a mistake. It's an error. It's just, uh, you know,
someone's typed the wrong data into the spreadsheet,
or they've run the wrong calculation, or they've made a copy and paste their,
when they were like taking our data from their statistical program into their
word document, which they were writing their scientific paper in,
which seems like such a kind of low grade mistake,
but it happens all the time in science. Um, and so, yeah,
that's probably the grim test can really be, can really be useful.
And there are very similar tests that are related to that. Um,
some of which also have good acronyms, which had, um,
James Henderson and Nick Cronin have come up with that, um, that can,
that can do similar things for other types of data. You know,
this one works for questionnaires where you have zero to five or whatever,
but there are other types of data that we would want to do something. And the,
and there are other algorithms that kind of check, um,
the P values that we were discussing before. You know, have you written,
have you written down the right P value in your study? If not, again,
it might be, you've made a mistake somewhere. Um, and, and,
and various other ways of, um, of looking and just saying,
does this data look as if it came about through natural normal means,
or does it look as if it's been tampered with, or if it's,
or if it's just mistaken.
Yeah. Yeah. And do you think that, um,
your opinion is mainstream, does it anger, scientists,
do you think it's being taken notice of,
is everyone getting their house in order to the extent that psychology seems to
be? I mean, there was.
Huge debate in psychology. Uh, when, you know, when the,
the replication crisis started coming about and people started doing replication
attempts and so on, and there were psychologists who came along and said,
this is useless. You're not doing the right thing. You're not running my,
you know, you're not running my experiment correctly,
so no wonder you're gonna not get a replication of it.
You changed one tiny aspect of it.
And so how do you expect to find the same result and their response to that as
well?
If the result doesn't survive one tiny aspect being changed in the experiment,
then probably it wasn't that important to resolve in the first place. Um, but,
um, but the, um, uh, across other fields, I, again, there's cause for optimism,
because I think a lot of people are catching onto this.
A lot of journals are starting to change. Um, you know,
the idea where you submit your first part of your paper before you,
before you collect the data that's being instituted at lots and lots of
journals, not just in psychology, it's called the registered reports. Um,
and it's, it's, it's, it's being instituted, um,
lots and lots and lots of journals learn in those different fields. Um,
open science data sharing is becoming a thing I think in many respects because
the technology is, is, is, is better now. I mean, just a few years ago,
you had to actually physically fit all your information on pages of paper,
uh, that were in the journal. No, of course you can share data much more easily.
There are repositories online that you can upload your data set to,
you can download other people's data, run the analysis again,
you can put all your code up there, you know, run everything. So, you know,
the technology is, is, is no barrier. So more fields can actually, you know,
make the change. It's one thing that I discuss in the book is that,
is that making, getting people on board with these changes is one thing,
but making it easier for them to do it is, is, is really the, is the best way.
And, um, uh, yeah, so you do see these,
these changes and you see other fields, um, you know,
so ecology and evolution is one that's really going to come on board.
You see a lot of papers saying, Hmm,
all these psychologists might have a point that we're doing all these incorrect
analysis. Maybe we should look at our own fields.
I saw a paper in criminology that did the same thing that said, Oh,
how much of this criminology research is actually is actually not useful at all.
And so, um, uh, you know, you're starting to see, you're starting to see these,
uh, uh,
issues being discussed in lots of different fields and actually someone that
some of them, sometimes they had to just have different words to, to use it.
So in medicine, instead of P hacking,
they talk about outcome switching in clinical trials,
which is where your trial was actually, um, was planned to be about.
I had pill that reduces headache, but actually it turned out that it reduced,
uh, I dunno, anxiety. And so you say, uh, Oh, uh,
we were always doing a study on anxiety all along,
and that's basically what P hacking is, but it's just called a different name.
So, you know, there's,
there's kind of convergent discussions across different fields of all these
problems. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, um,
I think we've reached the end of the time of the podcast. Um, but, uh,
that's at least something to hopeful for the future.
And if people want to find out more and genuinely it's, uh,
it's entertaining and it's not all stats and there's a lot of fun
stuff in it.
Science fiction is currently out now. Thanks so much. Thanks for having me on.